neutron stars are one of the most
extreme and violent things in the
universe
giant atomic nuclei only a few
kilometers in diameter but as massive as
stars
and they owe their existence to the
death of something majestic
[Music]
stars exist because of a fragile balance
the mass of millions of billions of
trillions of tons of hot plasma are
being pulled inwards by gravity and
squeeze material together with so much
force that nuclei fuse
hydrogen fuses into helium
this releases energy which pushes
against gravity and tries to escape as
long as this balance exists stars are
pretty stable
eventually the hydrogen will be
exhausted
medium stars like our sun go through a
giant phase where they burn helium into
carbon and oxygen before they eventually
turn into white dwarfs
but in stars many times the mass of our
sun things get interesting when the
helium is exhausted
for a moment the balance of pressure and
radiation tips and gravity winds
squeezing the star tighter than before
the core burns hotter and faster while
the outer layers of the stars swell by
hundreds of times fusing heavier and
heavier elements
carbon burns to neon in centuries neon
to oxygen in a year oxygen to silicon in
months and silicon to iron in a day
and then
death
iron is nuclear ash it has no energy to
give and cannot be fused
the fusion suddenly stops and the
balance ends
without the outward pressure from fusion
the core is crushed by the enormous
weight of the star above it
what happens now is awesome and scary
particles like electrons and protons
really don't want to be near each other
but the pressure of the collapsing star
is so great that electrons and protons
fuse into neutrons which then get
squeezed together as tightly as in
atomic nuclei
an iron ball the size of the earth is
squeezed into a ball of pure nuclear
matter the size of a city
but not just the core the whole star
implodes gravity pulling the outer
layers in at 25 percent the speed of
light
this implosion bounces off the iron core
producing a shock wave that explodes
outwards and catapults the rest of the
star into space
this is what we call a supernova
explosion and it will outshine entire
galaxies
what remains of the star is now a
neutron star
its mass is around a million times the
mass of the earth but compressed to an
object about 25 kilometers wide
it's so dense that the mass of all
living humans would fit into one cubic
centimeter of neutron star matter
that's roughly a billion tonnes in a
space the size of a sugar cube
put another way that's mount everest in
a cup of coffee
from the outside a neutron star is
unbelievably extreme
its gravity is the strongest outside
black holes and if it were any denser it
would become one
light is bent around it meaning you can
see the front and parts of the back
their surfaces reach a million degrees
celsius compared to a measly 6000
degrees for our sun
okay let's look inside a neutron star
although these giant atomic nuclei are
stars in many ways they're also like
planets with solid crusts over a liquid
core
the crust is extremely hard
the outermost layers are made of iron
left over from the supernova squeezed
together in a crystal lattice with a sea
of electrons flowing through them
going deeper gravity squeezes nuclei
closer together
we find fewer and fewer protons as most
merge to neutrons
until we reach the base of the crust
here nuclei are squeezed together so
hard that they start to touch
protons and neutrons rearrange making
long cylinders or sheets enormous nuclei
with millions of protons and neutrons
shaped like spaghetti and lasagna which
physicists call nuclear pasta
nuclear pasta is so dense that it may be
the strongest material in the universe
basically unbreakable
lumps of pasta inside a neutron star can
even make mountains at most a few
centimeters high but many times as
massive as the himalayas
eventually beneath the pasta we reach
the core
we're not really sure what the
properties of matter are when they're
squeezed this hard protons and neutrons
might dissolve into an ocean of quarks a
so-called quark gluon plasma
some of those quarks might turn into
strange quarks making a sort of strange
matter with properties so extreme that
we made a whole video about it
or maybe they just stay protons and
neutrons
no one knows for sure and that's why we
do science
that's all pretty heavy stuff literally
so let's go back out into space
when neutron stars first collapse they
begin to spin very very fast like a
ballerina pulling her arms in
neutron stars are celestial ballerinas
spinning many times per second
this creates pulses because their
magnetic field creates a beam of radio
waves which passes every time they spin
these radio pulsars are the best known
type of neutron star about 2 000 are
known of in the milky way
these magnetic fields are the strongest
in the universe a quadrillion times
stronger than earth's after they're born
they're called magnets until they calm
down a little
but the absolute best kind of neutron
stars are friends with other neutron
stars
by radiating away energy as
gravitational waves ripples and space
time their orbits can decay and they can
crash into and kill each other in a kill
and over explosion that spews out a lot
of their guards
when they do the conditions become so
extreme that for a moment heavy nuclei
are made again
it's not fusion putting nuclei together
this time but heavy neutron-rich matter
falling apart and reassembling
only very recently we've learned that
this is probably the origin of most of
the heavy elements in the universe like
gold uranium and platinum and dozens
more
so then our two neutron stars collapse
and become a black hole dying yet again
not only do stars have to die to create
elements they have to die twice
over millions of years these atoms will
mix back into the galaxy but some of
them end up in a cloud which gravity
pulls together to form stars and planets
repeating the cycle
our solar system is one example and the
remains of those neutron stars that came
before us are all around us
our entire technological modern world
was built out of the elements neutron
stars made in eons past sending these
atoms on a 13 billion year journey to
come together and make us and our world
and that's pretty cool
[Music]
until then we can look at them on paper
the 12020 human space era calendar has
arrived you can order it now until we
sell out and then never again
visit the cloudy cities of venus
dyson swarm assembly on mercury and
cross the borders of our solar system
shipping from the us and from europe for
the first time but we deliver to every
country all over the world
you could also get a plushie or hoodie
or poster
we have some sweet deals for you
get it for christmas for your friends
families and kids or to distract
yourself from the fact that there are
100 billion billion earth-like planets
in the habitable zone of sun-like stars
in the observable universe
and you will never visit any of them
the last few years we've sold them all
so no rush but the clock is ticking
getting stuff from our shop is one of
the best ways to support kotzkazak
because of you we can keep this channel
free for everyone and make more
beautiful things a happy interstellar
year 12020
[Music]